>> Tucker: LET'S SAY YOU'RE
TRYING TO STAFF A SOCIAL MEDIA
SITE.
SO IT'S A TECH BUSINESS, MAKE
TECH PEOPLE.
SOFTWARE ENGINEERS.
HIRE ADMINISTRATIVE STAFF.
LAWYERS, CATERER, FLAK OR TWO.
MAYBE AN INTERIOR DECORATOR.
HOW MANY SPIES WOULD YOU HIRE?
PROBABLY NONE.
SPIES HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE MISSION OF A SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANY.
THEY WOULDN'T BE NEEDED AND YOU
WOULDN'T HIRE ANY OPERA SINGERS
EITHER.
YET FOR SOME REASON, TWITTER
NEEDED A LOT OF SPIES.
THE UPPER RANKS OF TWITTER WE
NOW KNOW WERE ABSOLUTELY LOADED
WITH PEOPLE THAT ONCE DID INTEL
WORK FOR GOVERNMENT AGENCIES, AT
LEAST 15 OF THESE PEOPLE AND
POSSIBLY MANY MORE.
MOST OF THEM WERE HIRED IN THE
WAKE OF DONALD TRUMP'S ELECTION.
WHAT WERE THESE PEOPLE DOING ALL
DAY?
WHAT WAS SUPPOSEDLY A SOCIAL
MEDIA COMPANY?
THAT'S THE QUESTION, ISN'T IT?
WE KNOW JAMES BAKER CAME FROM
THE FBI.
HE'S BEEN ACCUSED OF CENSORING
AND INCRIMINATING FILES BEFORE
ELON MUSK COULD RELEASE THEM TO
THE PUBLIC.
HE WAS FIRED FOR THAT.
BUT HOW ABOUT CHARLES SMITH OF
TWITTER'S TRUST AND SAFETY
DEPARTMENT?
HE JOINED TWITTER AFTER WORKING
AT U.S. CYBER COMMAND.
HOW ABOUT A DIRECTOR OF NAVAL
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE?
WHAT WAS HE DOING OR DOUG HUNT
OR DOUGLAS TURNER, KAREN WALSH,
VINCENT LUCERA.
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WORK FOR THE
FBI AS WELL AND SO ON.
IT WASN'T JUST AMERICAN INTEL
OFFICERS THAT FOUND A HOME AT
TWITTER.
THE HEAD OF SECURITY LOST HIS
JOB BECAUSE HE COMPLAINED ABOUT
THE LEVEL OF CONTROL THAT
FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES
HAD OVER TWITTER'S OPERATION.
THERE WERE OPERATIVES ON
TWITTER'S PAYROLL FROM OTHER
GOVERNMENTS INCLUDING CHINA AND
INDIA AND HAD ACCESS TO PRIVATE
USER DATA.
THOSE ARE THE DETAILS THAT WE
KNOW ABOUT.
ELON MUSK WAS ASKED HOW MANY
FORMER FBI AGENTS ARE EMPLOYED
BY TWITTER?
HE WOULDN'T SAY.
IT'S ALL WEIRD.
COULD IT BE THAT WHILE THE REST
OF US IMAGINED THAT TWITTER WAS
A SOCIAL MEDIA SITE, A PLACE TO
VENT ABOUT POLITICS AND SPORTS
AND THE KARDSHIANS, COULD IT BE
THAT TWITTER WAS PRIMARILY A
PROPAGANDA TOOL AND INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING APPARATUS FOR A
VARIETY OF INTEL AGENCIES?
YES, THAT'S POSSIBLE.
YOU CAN SEE WHY VARIOUS
GOVERNMENTS WOULD WANT ACCESS TO
THE INFORMATION THAT TWITTER
HAD.
KEEP IN MIND THAT TWITTER'S
DIRECT MESSAGE TO DM FEATURE, A
FUNCTION AS A PRIVATE TEXAS APP
FOR THE WORLD'S MOST PROMINENT
PEOPLE.
IF YOU WANTED TO KNOW WHO HIGH
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS REALLY
THOUGHT OR WHAT WELL-INFORMED
SOURCES WERE TELLING REPORTERS
OFF THE REPORT, YOU'D WANT TO
SEE THOSE MESSAGES.
DID TWITTER EXECUTIVES SHARE
THOSE PRIVATE MESSAGES WITH
ANYONE OUTSIDE THE COMPANY
WUT -- WITHOUT A WARRANT?
WE SUSPECT THEY DID.
THINK ABOUT IT.
IF TWITTER HAS BEEN FUNCTIONING
AS THE ARM OF GOVERNMENT INTEL
AGENCIES AND IT HAS BEEN, ITS
INTERNAL DOCUMENTS WILL CONTAIN
INFORMATION ABOUT ALL KINDS OF
THINGS.
NOT JUST ABOUT THE SILENCING OF
DONALD TRUMP.
NOT JUST ABOUT TONY FAUCI'S LIES
ABOUT THE COVID SHOT.
NO, INFORMATION ABOUT BIG
HISTORY SHAPING EVENTS.
THE SABOTAGE OF NORD STREAM TWO.
THE POISON GAS ATTACKS IN SYRIA.
THE IMPRISONMENT OF JULIAN
ASSANGE.
THE THEFT OF INCRIMINATE
IN
E-MAILS BEHIND THE DNC AND MUCH,
MUCH MORE.
IN OTHER WORDS, ELON MUSK NOW
HAS CONTROL OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT TROVE OF SECRET
INFORMATION EVER TO RESIDE IN
PRIVATE HANDS.
SO FAR WE HAVE NOT SEEN MUCH O